episode three of The Last of Us just
aired an episode concentrating all
around Bill played by Nick Offerman I've
been looking forward to this one bill
everyone's favorite apocalypse
curmudgeon so just so you know this is
gonna be a spoiler video I'm going to
talk about everything that happens in
the episode not gonna jump forward and
talk about things that happen later in
the game but if you're just watching
episode to episode you don't know
anything about the story as a whole you
are safe I mean you're safe if you've
watched this episode if not you should
watch it first time you know what I'm
saying so in the game The Last of Us one
of the characters that Joel and Ellie
run across is a character named Bill
Bill clearly has history with Joel
clearly doesn't really like Joel that
much so this is the episode where we get
to see that character and this is also
the episode we see the deviations in the
story deviations that don't affect the
story of The Last of Us as a whole did
you see Joel and Ellie in this episode
yeah I mean Joel's gonna be like no
we're not getting close at all I don't
care but he does care because in the end
he still didn't want her to see the
skeletons that were dead bodies he
wanted to protect her from that you
don't protect a kid from that if you
don't give a [__] again we see that
nugget that Joel Heart of Gold there I
like that and I won't lie the fungal
apocalypse looks appealing for the
second reason in a row first reason was
the fact that a fungus caused the
apocalypse caused all these infected
zombie walker-esque folks civilization
Falls everyone's Gonna Hate fungus which
means no more mushrooms on pizza ever
the second reason koi not Mortal Kombat
2 machines they're still around as long
as there's Mortal Combat when
civilization Falls I will be fine I'll
be happyish so one thing I found of note
as I'm taking mental notes on watching
the episode mental notes that'll help me
out when I'm word vomiting in my video I
was like this is the first episode that
did not have a flashback at the
beginning spoke a little too soon on
that one this episode did not have a
flashback at the beginning this episode
was a flashback at first you get a
little insight into the fungus and how
it spread because Ellie was like how did
this thing spread Jill breaks it down
it's like well it got into the food
flour sugar whatever and then every
everyone just kind of ate it at the same
time because that was what went out that
was a Friday by Monday we were in
shitsville one weekend you start your
bender on Friday and before your
hangover even clears up on Monday
civilization has fallen then it goes
back 20 years you see Nick Offerman
playing Bill everyone gets moved out of
his town
and then they die they do this
Schindler's List kind of thing you know
with the girl with the red dress and
Schindler's List and you're like oh
That's Heavy there's a blanket with
rainbows in this one basically the
government was like yeah everyone you're
you're going to shelter if there's no
room
you're going in the ground we're not
going to tell you that because we're the
government but trust us then you see
Bill the gun toting conspiracy theorist
and his bunker his bomb shelter the
security cameras about 78 000 of
firearms lining his walls but he was
like no thank you for trusting the
government showing that the difference
between a conspiracy theorist and a
realist is no longer six months no
it's a [__] weekend then bill
fortifies this little neighborhood and
he's like I'm gonna live here then
someone runs into one of his traps he's
in this hole in the ground and you're
like okay so this is why bill becomes
the grumpy [__] we know him to be
which is kind of half rise right for the
game not really for this episode I'll
get there so rule number one the
apocalypse you just don't trust anybody
but Bill does and he has dinner with
this dude and there's a scene where he's
playing the piano he's like oh no no no
don't turn your back to the good like
you're playing the piano and you're
concentrating on the music dudes behind
you this is it this is when it goes bad
it doesn't it it all just it's fine and
they start a relationship together and I
was like Frank building for I know the
Bill and Frank right Frank as in dead
Frank I knew I recognized that I'm okay
so this is why bill becomes the grumpy
[__] we know in the Apocalypse in the
future oh it's gonna go so bad for Belle
here we go so that's really what the
episode is about is Bill and Frank and
their relationship over the course of
the next couple decades they fortified
this neighborhood this neighborhood that
only got raided once in 20 years I am
calling [__] on that in the game I
get it where Bill is it looks like it
looks like a lot of infected maybe
you'll get a can of beans out of that
screw that noise but in the show the
houses have electricity there's
fortification there's clearly people
there and most definitely resources one
raiding party ever attempted and that
was it and granted they were [__]
themselves they're like running into the
flamethrowers like their NPCs or
something half expected these idiots to
die like
and he runs into Jolin test which was
great to see Anna Torv again she's not
just out of the show entirely I mean she
might be from now on depends on how many
flashbacks we get so long story short
Frank comes down with some sort of
illness looks like ALS might not be ALS
I don't know this is where the comment
section is going to be like clearly it
was I'm sorry we didn't cover terminal
illnesses in the projection booth at the
movie theater in which I worked before I
did YouTube point is he has this
degenerative disease that is getting
worse so he tells Bill he's like this is
my last night we're gonna crush up a
bunch of Vicodin we're gonna have a
great day in the meal tonight we're
gonna pour the Vicodin in my wine I'm
gonna drink it I'm Gonna Die In Your
Arms almost technically not Vicodin stop
Bill agrees to it which he also slammed
a bunch of pills with his wine he was
like we're going out together I was like
but Bill's gonna live through it because
Bill's grumpy bill in the apocalypse we
know that no they just die together this
is the deviation I was talking about
folks Bill dies with his boyfriend
actually husband they ended up getting
married and Bill's just gone for the
character episode that this was it was
actually a great way to go it was a
great way to end it because it makes
complete and total sense if you hold to
bill that you know from the game you're
gonna be like I feel like that guy would
have just survived because he clearly
did survive after Frank was gone and
he's a grumpy dick as a result and
that's what happens and that's how that
goes but if you look at this episode as
the character piece there's it makes
sense still survive and he survives the
apocalypse and he gets into this
relationship which becomes this
beautiful relationship over the course
of the next two decades Bill's like dude
I've lived these past 20 years or so
with you in a more fulfilling manner
than I'm ever going to live without you
in this [__] world what did we call it
uh shitsville right it's everywhere it
makes sense to go out together you're
just going to be surviving you're not
going to be living you've already done
the living so do I get it for the
episode yes did I want to see Nick
Offerman play grumpy Bill and do
dealings with Joel and Ellie in live
action absolutely we all know what's
coming next episode next episode is the
person in the street saying help I'm
hurt there are things in the last of us
that stand out as iconic bummer is um
Joel and Ellie dealing with Bill that's
one of them for me the other one is Joel
and Ellie in the truck and they're
driving down the road while someone's on
the road saying they're hurt you know
why I'm looking forward to that because
as long as they don't deviate from the
games Joel from the games loves killing
folk I know that because as I was
playing Joel in the games well I love
killing folks I didn't just Escape into
the weeds no no we gotta get to
murdering humans the next episode might
be that time but I really like the
episode as a character episode but me
personally I always found the world of
The Last of Us was just a little cooler
because Bill was out there in it you
just I liked his character in the games
liked his character in here too
satis no longer around alright so The
Last of Us episode three have you seen
it how do you feel the show's going are
you liking it so far every time Joel and
Ellie start bonding and getting a little
closer you just look forward to the end
I do I just I can't wait to see it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]